President
Pérezés has called elections
for May 12 because the Parliament
has not supported the budgets
The autonomous regions they presented.
It was rejected every game except PSG.
What has surprised most
was that the commons did not support them,
but in the last few days there has been 1 mess for 1
project to build in Tarragona
1 hotel and casino complex
as if they were Las Vegas.
The hard rock,
because of what you hear out there,
They have been there until the last minute
negotiating to see if they approved them,
but nothing.
The commoners say they don't want it to go ahead.
And after that
Pedro Sanchez told his team
to try to approve the budgets
for 2,024,
because with all the messed up stuff,
it was very difficult to get all the parties to agree
independentistas who are key to approving them,
so they will go to work directly
2,025 budgets.
This is factual.
If it follows us like this,
it would be crazy